[Music]
no matter how busy with the manny the
middle aspect always so much harder and
when you're swimming six to ten hours by
yourself
i started running out of things to think
about
your mind starts getting exhausted
my name is chris frame and i swam the
entire length of the mississippi river
it took me 181 days
[Music]
the mississippi river is 2
320 miles long
beginning in minnesota it empties into
the gulf of mexico
and in 2015 chris rang took it on to
raise awareness and honor gold star
families
the gold star family is a family that's
lost a loved one in service to our
country which is truly inspiring so i
was like i want to do
something
so he took on the mighty mississippi
it's an amazing powerful river so you
don't really know what to expect
we did as much research as possible in
what you'll face in the mississippi
you see a lot of wildlife out there
you'll see bald eagles flying around a
lot of alligators stuff like that
one thing that i was really kind of
surprised about was how big the swells
get in the river you know i didn't
expect 10 plus foot swells
the only time that i would not swim
was when there was a fog so if there's
storms still swimming through the storms
you know we did hit some pretty big
storms going down the river one storm he
remembers in particular we're making
good time and before you know it sky is
just pitch black it's just sideways rain
winds changing constant direction the
lightning's flashing around and
you can feel it it's hitting so closely
actually you can feel it
in the water
and there's nothing really can do at
that point you know it's you're waiting
out
i've always had a high respect and
appreciation for nature
there's days that it took me an hour
just to go half a mile
just seeing how quickly that river can
change not only from weather but you
know from currents
you know so a new appreciation for what
that river itself for what can come from
what you'll face in the mississippi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
participate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's so funny i get this
question all the time do you still
remember how it felt to drown
it was a crippling feeling i was
suffocating underwater now i've made it
my job to conquer my fear and to help to
get these kids swim lessons and learn
how to respect the water
[Music]
my name is colin jones i was in the
olympics in 2008 and 2012 and i love to
give swim lessons cullen jones is a
four-time olympic medalist swimmer for
team usa right after getting the gold
medal in 2008 they put the drowning
rates in front of me
and i learned that 70 of african
americans nearly 60 of latin americans
nearly 40 percent of caucasians don't
notice them so it's a big problem all
over the us
i think the reason that you don't see as
many african americans in swimming is
because there's such a stigma that
black people don't swim and this is
something that needs to be broken
because we are losing children you're
losing adults and it's
something that can be changed by swim
lessons
swimming lessons are so important to
kids to me personally because i was
almost one of those kids and part of
this statistic
when cullen was just five years old he
almost drowned on a water slide at an
amusement park they had to come out and
grab me and resuscitate me because i was
under water for about 30 seconds and i
think what's important about the story
is that i was fully supervised i mean it
was that easy and that quick for me to
go underwater that could have been my
last day on this earth
and with that near-death experience
colin has made it his platform to bring
water safety education to kids from all
backgrounds
the way that i'm trying to change my
community is definitely with working
with the make splash initiative i knew
this was my way of giving back to a
sport that's given me so much
once you learn how to swim it's like
riding a bike you never forget
so take the time learn how to swim
[Music]
when you're looking out from the
platform
usually
it's just water everywhere which makes
you feel really really tiny jumping into
this
giant ocean
i'm rachelle simpson
and i'm a world champion cliff driver
[Applause]
it's very similar to olympic diving the
only difference is at the end we're
going to land on our feet
as i climb up on the platform you hear
the wind blowing in your ears
sometimes there's seagulls zooming
around my head
i hear the announcer call my name
it's kind of like i'm going into this
hallway and the sound slowly cutting out
because that's when i'm going into focus
that's when i set my feet and then my
arms go up
i count to three
and go
your body's on autopilot and your brain
is just sitting back watching front
somersault twist second somersault tight
position
[Music]
when you hit the water at first you
don't notice anything and then it starts
all coming back you create bubbles
underneath the surface and you feel
those bubbles pushing you back up to the
surface quite a cool feeling actually
[Music]
when you come up take a breath of air
and the rush of adrenaline just like
you've been holding it off
and not even breathing until you hit
that water
[Applause]
each time i enter the water it's another
successful moment of convincing my brain
to do something i'm scared of but each
time i get a sense of empowerment when i
overcome it
i love it
[Applause]
[Music]
on eli malk island in palau
there is a lake like no other
[Music]
the saltwater lake was once connected to
the ocean but as the island changed it
was closed off
now in isolation it is filled with a
jellyfish species found nowhere else
the golden jellyfish
these cryptic creatures spend their days
migrating across the lake from one side
to the other following the path of the
sun which feeds the fast-growing algae
that this jellyfish species feeds on
and with no predators to keep them in
check the jellyfish swarm and fill the
lake like a cloudy dream
it's safe for humans to swim in because
though these jellyfish do have stingers
they are too small to be felt by humans
gliding through this place feels
otherworldly
[Music]
you